buen trabajo en llegar hasta aquí ahora
es tu turno de conducir hasta ahora
construimos un sistema masa resorte en
dos dimensiones es bastante genial y es
la base para muchas simulaciones
recuerda que en la lección 1 usamos
múltiples resortes conectados como estos
para simular cabello en este vídeo te
voy a mostrar cómo agregar un segundo
resorte y una masa más a tu sistema
primero vamos a dibujar un nuevo
diagrama de fuerzas para ver qué está
pasando vamos a llamar a nuestras dos
masas más a uno y más a dos ya nuestros
dos resortes resorte uno y resorte dos
primero vamos a pensar acerca de las
nuevas fuerzas que actúan sobre la masa
uno como antes tenemos la fuerza de
gravedad que actúa hacia abajo una
fuerza del resorte uno que tira hacia
arriba hacia el anclaje y una fuerza de
amortiguamiento que actúa en la
dirección opuesta sin embargo ahora hay
una nueva fuerza de vida al nuevo
resorte que conecta la masa 2 en este
caso el desplazamiento que utilizamos
para calcular la fuerza de resorte 2 es
la diferencia entre la posición de las
dos masas la posición de la masa 2 - la
posición de la masa 1 y también hay una
fuerza de amortiguamiento
que se resiste a la fuerza del resorte 2
así que necesitamos agregar estas dos
nuevas fuerzas a las componentes xy del
cálculo de la fuerza neta de la masa 1
ahora considera la nueva masa que
agregamos va a experimentar la fuerza de
gravedad y también la fuerza del resorte
2 - la fuerza de amortiguamiento que se
opone al resorte 2 y eso es todo lo que
hay que modificar en nuestro cálculo
hasta arriba vamos a agregar nuevas
variables iniciales para representar
tanto la posición como la velocidad de
la masa 2 voy a hacer que la posición de
la masa 2 esté por debajo de la masa 1
la velocidad inicial de la masa 2
también es cero para agregar una nueva
masa 2 tenemos que duplicar todas las
ecuaciones que usamos para la masa 1 sin
embargo hay dos diferencias clave para
el cálculo de la fuerza del resorte de
la masa 2 usaremos la posición de la
masa 2 - la posición de la masa 1 es
decir más tu posición menos masjuán
posición como nuestro desplazamiento y
para el cálculo de la fuerza neta para
la masa 2 tenemos la fuerza del resorte
de la masa 2 menos
de amortiguamiento de la masa 2 o bien
más tu spring force menos más tu
'dumping' force por último sólo tenemos
que dibujar el nuevo círculo y la línea
para esta masa y este resorte la nueva
línea se va a extender desde la masa 1 a
la masa 2 el nuevo círculo será el
centro de la posición de la masa 2
y eso nos da esto los sistemas más
resortes son muy poderosos en pixar no
solo los usamos para el cabello los
árboles en un gran dinosaurio también se
simularon con un sistema masa resorte
más o menos como el cabello pero tenía
que representar la estructura de un
árbol los árboles tienen ramas así que
las simulamos al tener muchos segmentos
de recta unidos a otros como si
tuviéramos cabellos unidos a otros
cabellos en lugar de sólo estar unidos
al cuero cabelludo incluso a la ropa se
simula usando masas y resortes en
valiente medida tenía varios vestidos
que necesitábamos simular y cada uno
tenía sus propios valores para los
resortes estos valores se escogieron
para imitar diferentes tipos de telas
como lana algodón y satin sanz como
puedes ver los sistemas más resortes son
super útiles para modificar y simular
todo tipo de cosas diferentes ve si
puedes pensar en otros materiales que se
podrían crear usando sistemas más
resorte y ese es el objetivo de este
proyecto final tu trabajo es modificar
este programa para hacer lo que sea que
puedas imaginar tu programa derivado
aparecerá automáticamente abajo
de derivados junto con los de todos los
demás y realmente te animo a que revises
otras creaciones para obtener nuevas
ideas de inspiración diviértete y sé
feliz explorando